una sola tierra es el lema de este 2022
y dicen ustedes que comportamientos
sostenibles se reducirían nuestras
emisiones entre un 40 y un 70 por ciento
para el 2050 es realista pensar que ese
cambio si se puede dar
buenos días muchas gracias si el día
mundial del medio ambiente precisamente
se trata de alzar la voz para proteger
el planeta pero en esta ocasión queremos
mostrar que el poder de la gente cuenta
y por eso estamos contabilizando los
compromisos de todo tipo de personas en
todo tipo de roles de cómo están
contribuyendo a este cambio pero
evidentemente como comentas nos quedan
pocos años para poder dar ese giro
bien este año y el país anfitrión de la
conmemoración es suecia qué acciones se
direccionan desde la onu en la campaña
del 2022 para recuperar los ecosistemas
y usted no se mencionaba este registro
de eventos que se pueden hacer en la
página de la onu
si hay muchos compromisos que están
mostrando tanto escuelas como empresas
gobiernos pero sobre todo estamos muy
preocupados en la región con que los
costos de la adaptación al cambio
climático están aumentando porque la
crisis climática no se está reduciendo
al nivel que queremos que es bajar al
50% las emisiones para el 2030 y que eso
se une a la degradación de los
ecosistemas que nos está haciendo más
vulnerables y por eso este año empezó el
decenio de restauración de ecosistemas
para intentar regenerar otra vez todos
estos servicios de agua alimentos
protección que nos da la naturaleza y
que estamos perdiendo sin necesidad no
bueno piedad y finalmente las acciones
individuales si son muy importantes en
el cuidado del medio ambiente pero ya
llegamos a un punto en el que la
responsabilidad debe ser asumida por los
gobiernos y por las industrias usted qué
opina
sí yo creo que todos somos responsables
lo cual significa que todos podemos
ayudar pero deberíamos hacer que los
modos de vida sostenibles sean la opción
habitual tengamos acceso a energías
renovables al transporte sostenible que
podamos participar en la reforestación
en no utilizar plásticos y como dice
esto necesita obviamente de la anuencia
de gobiernos y de las empresas privadas
también no solo de la del compromiso de
la ciudadanía y el consumidor mire una
de las crisis que más fuertemente se
evidencian es la pérdida de fauna y de
flora más de un millón de especies que
están en peligro de extinción es un
número récord que se puede hacer para
recuperar pues las especies bueno lo que
estamos promoviendo es por un lado que
las áreas protegidas aumenten y
funcionen pero también eso no es
suficiente hay que conectar esas áreas
protegidas y hay que regenerar algunas
zonas por ejemplo un tercio de las
tierras agrícolas están degradadas en el
mundo esas tierras si ya no producen
suficientes se pueden regenerar como
ecosistemas y darle hogar a estas
especies que están desapareciendo